nobody really questions a lot of what is
being said
so we all tend to be distracted by the
shiny objects and
the lovely features that are painted for
us augmented reality we're going to live
in virtu with virtual avatars and spend
virtual money and things like that but
no one really sort of questions whether
this is actually the best way to
resolve or solve some of humanity's
biggest challenges
what's an anti-futurist
i get asked this all the time it's a
little bit of a marketing spin
i think it goes to uh uh perhaps bronwyn
and i's um
our particular uh viewpoint of the
future which is
if you look at the pop culture futurists
like peter diamantis
and ray kurzweil they paint a very
specific uh
version of utopia which is everyone will
merge and merge with machines and become
one with the singularity
um and my particular take is more akin
to
i cast a large dollop of cynicism um
on top of all of it and just and kind of
take a step back and say well is this
really
you know the preferred version that we
want to actually prescribe to
and and why why should we believe that
these two men or
these particular futurists who have the
loudest voice
are the right ones that we should be
following so my take on futurism or
anti-futurism
is really a more pragmatic and realistic
approach uh
born out of the fact i used to be a
chief evangelist of a technology company
so i used to put on a lot of the spin
and the happy version
you know happy clappy version and stuff
like that and hug trees and now i hug
trees because
you know the trees are disappearing and
i realize that you know technology is
isn't as uh rosy as what other people
paint it to be
so i kind of take um a very sort of um
negative stance in a sense towards
these particular futures that other
people want us to
to to prescribe and and walk towards
uh with blinkers on in a sense what do
you mean criticisms
of the status quo the dominant guards
ideology for futurism
um i
i don't think there are enough younger
voices in the room for one
so my criticism for futurism in general
is there aren't enough
younger voices in the room um so it
tends to be sort of old fuddy-duddy
guard
um that kind of sort of has a very sort
of um
you know i i would guess blinkered and
old way of manifesting what they believe
is a future
fit for humanity the second thing is
which
goes towards bronwyn and i's um you know
a
very sort of strong stance is that
nobody really questions
um i think a lot of what is being said
so we all tend to
be distracted by the shiny objects and
the lovely features that are painted for
us augmented reality
we're going to live in virtu with
virtual avatars and spend virtual money
and things like that
but no one really sort of questions
whether this is actually the best way to
resolve or solve some of humanity's
biggest challenges like poverty
uh homelessness you know inequality you
know
our sense of self of what we are worth
as people so
um i would you know my other criticism
apart from
let's speak to the younger people behind
us who want to take have a stake in that
that future is let's actually stop and
question
each particular step along the way and
just ask is this the right step that we
take
and it goes towards the you know the
future cone
scenario where i think a lot of them are
rather than looking at the preferable
future they're away wandering off
along the um you know the the one that
they
they kind of prefer themselves so it's
again it goes back to that biased view
again this is the one i want
but it's not might not be the future
that everybody wants and it'd be nice
for people to just stop and
question that go for it
yeah i suppose i have quite a similar
view to theo but also a little bit more
divergence in that
my problem with conversations around the
future is that i do tend to be imposed
from above by the most powerful
wealthiest best connected voices in the
room and they tend to be quite binary
they're either selling you on a probable
dystopia or in a probable
utopia and that's a very very binary way
of thinking but they both
selling you and that's the key people
either selling you on inevitable doom
and gloom in order to get you to
essentially
fall under their will to do what they
want to do that's this is what
politicians like to do they like to talk
about
the negative only to sell the fear side
of the future so that you can listen to
what they say and you give up a whole
lot of your rights and your agency over
where we are headed
and that becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy on the other hand you've kind
of got people more in the private sector
selling you on complete like theo was
saying
this technological utopia this fully
automated luxury communism that awaits
us
all if once again we just fall in line
and do what they say and buy what they
are selling
and that for me is quite a huge problem
because both those roads sort of end up
in a future where most of us
are ending up giving up a whole lot of
our agency a whole lot of our ability
to direct and broaden that future cone
and instead of broadening our realm of
possibility because there are like
almost 8 billion of us on the planet we
should have lots of different ideas
instead we kind of being funneled into a
much
narrower idea of where we are headed
with a sense of inevitability
and i think that's what we really want
to sort of shake people out so none of
this is set the future starts
as the cover says now and it always
starts now we get to choose the next
step in every direction that we headed
so interesting that when you think about
futurism as an area of research
that the more that people become
dogmatic the less interesting futurism
is that you're constraining your own
futures by
putting your colors to one particular
flagpole or another and um
there's not many things where the person
that has the most clout or the most
power
or the most convincing advertising
campaign doesn't end up winning
right so i suppose that it is important
for people to just
and you are trying to encourage them to
do it in this book as well to think
about what sort of a future they want as
opposed to just listening to
people who ostensibly don't i don't can
you have a qualification in the future
i don't really think so i think that
people it's it's hours to create right
that's why we're sovereign individuals
so you go through a ton of
different examples different areas in
the book and i want to go through some
of those today so the first one
uh making it nice and positive was
warfare the future of warfare
that sounds about right
[Laughter]
well it's interesting i mean christina
um christina libby from
hypergiant wrote that one um
and she's got a particular viewpoint and
i and i think it prescribes to a lot of
what other people sort of think as well
which is it's become warfare's becoming
fully automated which means
our input and our agency and our on our
i guess the humanity side of uh if there
is a human the human
side of killing each other inside the
warfare
where was i going to go with that one i
wonder um you know that side has
actually been completely taken away
and you know we have examples of robot
you know robotic warfare
we have drone warfare and things like
that and we're giving up all of that
decision making
to um algorithms so there's that side
um and then there's also the cyber
warfare which is the eternal
war against um people hacking uh
various missions you know our computers
our infrastructure
our utilities uh to hold us to ransom
um and so warfare kind of sort of takes
many forms and in the future obviously
you've got that technological
layer upon it which kind of sort of
makes it even more dystopian
than it is i guess um but it also allows
people to
i guess the attack vector suddenly
becomes a lot more
uh wider and broader because everybody
can can take a little stab at it you
have script kiddies
writing little algorithms that are
polymorphic and and suddenly become
virus that take over
you know i've seen and a cryptocurrency
is
is quite an interesting one right now
because obviously it's supposed to be
this
you know um decentralized uh wealth of
money
um that you have you have your wallet
nobody can hack into it and things like
that and what we're finding is that
you know all this money is disappearing
and left right and center because
there are holes even in something as uh
you know as
as as complex as decentralized finance
so
it's um it's interesting i think our
like i said our attack vector is
becoming broader even though
we think it should be actually shrinking
through technology so
yeah decentralized finance sounds quite
quite nice but decentralized warfare
suddenly should give us all a pause for
thought and this is what technology is
doing it's democratizing all sorts of
things not necessarily just
things we want to have democratized
that's asking us to ask very different
questions
i think christina's chapter is quite
important in that it also shows
how warfare is almost becoming
de-civilized so what we saw
throughout sort of like the history of
warfare it started off being an
individual versus an individual
and we sort of outsourced the fighting
to soldiers and they would fight each
other
but now what's happening is we've got
soldiers and machines that are going
after civilians again so you've kind of
de-civilized that process and if you
actually look at what's going on in the
middle east
if you look at what's happening with out
out in the eastern side of europe and
what's happening is like what's bumping
into each other in the on the far
sides of asia too is that it seems to be
like centralized control whether that's
power or money because of course some of
these are private armies
that are involving these these various
different automated machines
are now using them as a form of terror
against civilians so civilians now
become part of warfare once again
so it is a conversation that we all have
to be aware of because these things are
out the bottle and it's not just drones
or and cyber technology it's also of
course all the bio warfare which we have
to be very
very aware of it only takes one guy and
it's a lot easier
to make a hugely destructive
civilization ending bio weapon in your
garage
than it is to make a nuclear bomb so we
have to be very very aware of these
things
and we have to start thinking again
around these ideas of centralization
decentralization
and how again the path is probably
somewhere in between the two of them
but there are some benefits to sometimes
having central control over very very
dangerous things and ideas
that's the problem right as you
democratize technology
and more people have access to
increasingly greater powers of
destruction
what you end up with is previously the
the worst damage that anybody could
cause was with a knife or a sword
but that same person can now 3d print
themselves a gun if they have the
resources for it
and then you just continue to roll the
clock forward and you go right okay so
in 500 years time what is the most basic
thing that anyone can do i can make my
own rocket ship
well fantastic how are we going to
police that how are we going to be able
to control that
nick bostrom has this example where he
talks about how it could have been
the way that physics was constructed in
this universe that if you put sand in a
microwave it made an atomic bomb
now by the quirk of chemistry and
physics that we have that isn't the case
but it's not that it couldn't have been
the case and as you continue to pull
these urn
the balls out of the urn right each one
of them could be something that's really
really bad
but it could be something that's just
sufficiently accessible enough
to cause some damage and that's yeah as
you've got a society that's ever growing
you have people feeling disaffected
you know the difference between i think
it's
the um school killings that you get in
japan
or china perhaps are people going around
with a knife
whereas how much destruction can you do
there versus how much destruction can
you see in america
and again you just continue to roll that
forward some unfortunate disaffected
person
trying to damage the world around them
and um yeah it makes for a
it makes for a scary future so what do
we do how do we protect ourselves
well what are we starting to see as
we're seeing a resurgence of essentially
a kind of a digitized version of
sort of serfdom that we kind of seeing
emerging in front of our eyes like theo
was talking about the world of crypto
too and what that is doing is
empowering vast amounts of wealth into
very small individual hands again sort
of decentralization has come full circle
back to sort of
centralization of massive amounts the
winklevoss twins currently
ruling half of the the universe of
crypto yeah exactly
yeah exactly or elon musk's gonna build
seats to like move markets and devastate
small children across
the world a trillion a trillion dollars
off the cryptocurrency market yeah
we've created quite an unstable system
there but what it's pointing to when you
tie that together with the ability of
people to literally develop private
armies is you end up with a world where
more and more of us are going to be
looking for essentially protection from
private players rather than from our
states because at the same time that
private hands are
developing a whole lot of power due to
decentralization states are at the same
time
losing that power losing that monopoly
over violence over currency
which is heading to quite a
destabilizing point in society
almost like a new sort of hobbesian
state of nature that we're going to have
to find a new equilibrium in
but the way we find that balance against
those rogue agents
is to essentially attach ourselves to
the protection of people who have
the means the money and the guns and
weapons essentially
to protect us and that's that's the sort
of the that's the
unspoken but kind of the spoken
base case future that we're sort of
stumbling into whether you're looking at
the sort of prophecies of the world
economic forum
or whether you're listening to what the
powerful mainly men in crypto are saying
they're essentially pointing us in that
direction once you start to connect the
dots
and this is why we want people involved
with the conversation because then this
is inevitable yet if
that doesn't fill you with joy now is
the time to say that
you know there's a place for both
regulation and education
in trying to solve our very very messy
very very wicked human problems
i myself do lean towards more liberty
and less rules but at the same time i've
met people and i think that
as much as i don't like rules to apply
to me i i'm quite kind of in favor of
them applying to
to other people so i recognize that
hypocrisy
yeah i um it seems almost like
a world in which similar to how the
american healthcare system is set up
where you have
healthcare insurance it might be the
fact that you need to pay
for some sort of digital private
security some physical private security
and then you've actually got a market
for these sort of mercenary
protection for higher companies almost
you know to
i live in south africa we've had private
security and private healthcare and
private education for even the middle
classes in the lower middle classes our
private school education costs less than
a state education although we have
essentially
or theoretically free state education
doesn't actually play out
in the real world and we pay for our
insecurity i live in a state complex so
we have on guards at the gate we have a
compound
this is like how i've grown up so it's
quite normal to me i'm like south africa
is a preview of this
very neo-feudal future we sort of
stumbling into
and then just this week we've seen a
couple of companies out in los angeles
where the whole defund the police
movement has
gained quite a lot of popular support at
the same time you've got rich people who
are now investing in a sort of tech
startup for
on-demand the sort of you know e-hailing
version of private security which south
african i know
very well but this is shocking america
tastes like uber
uber for goons with guns is that what it
is yeah
vigilante the right to arrest people
so yeah i've seen the future it's not
always cracked up to me everyone thinks
very very consciously about these things
everyone's going to be south africa
that's terrifying and the fact that
we're all laughing about it as well is
purely because it's so ridiculous and
terrifying there's no other outlet
for the emotion you just say well i've
i've got to laugh at it because the
alternative would be to break down in
despair in the corner
just weep well that's actually quite an
interesting point because
the natural reaction is to go oh how
stupid this will never happen blah blah
blah
and of course our apathy towards the
shock and the awe
and um is is is is becoming normalized
to the to the point where
it just happens under our feet and then
the next day you wake up
you know um you've got armed guards and
people posting leaflets going
would you like protection going to work
kind of sort of thing and it's like when
did this happen
well of course we stood laughing about
it last week yeah but
you missed the bulletin where you where
you had the opportunity to say no i
didn't want this
and again goes back to the book you know
you have a stake in the future
instead of you know being apathetic
about it actually
stand up and and saying yes this is fine
for me
no i don't want this for me what about
transportation what did you learn about
that
um flying cars i think doug writes about
flying cars
you're not gonna have one and you're not
gonna have one anytime soon well you're
not gonna own one you might get to ride
in one
um i think it's transportation's
um you know i'm gonna bob and weave on
this one as well because
i saw an interesting uh video where
in china they were trialling
what they called an autonomous
vehicle which drove along
the road um
essentially china invented the bus but
the way that they painted it was that
there was this autonomous vehicle that
had
many carriages that drove along the road
and followed the path of the road and i
just thought we'll hang on them and i've
i've you know i've i've kind of had
these in edinburgh for you know 50
100 years now you know and so of many
other countries but because it's
autonomous
um all of a sudden it's something new
and and what
so generally what we do what we find is
a lot of
ideas have been recycled for one um
on the transportation side we're not
going to see flying cars what you will
see is autonomous taxi drones for
example
where there will be either single
passenger or multi-passenger maybe
two three four family size nothing like
a flying bus let's put it that way
but again you know
not for the general public i would say
um for one
so for the uber rich and for the rich
who can afford to sort of call a taxi to
their
to their acreage in the backyard and
take them up to their skyscraper
penthouse
suite that's fine for the rest of us
it's roofing it down at the bottom of
the streets again
surely that would be democratized down
though as the technology becomes more
widespread you're going to inevitably
end up if there's a market there for it
you're going to continue to drop the
price and drop the price and drop the
price until you can match supply and
demand
yeah but at the same time i mean you
find all these
you know all these sort of technological
shifts and innovations are always
trialled and built
for specific cities in mind um
and so you have them that you know for
for
tesla and things like autonomous
transportation it's always it's always
trialled and built for
american roads where it's very long very
straight
huge cavernous roads um and it's all
grid-like patterns now if you if you
come to a city like
edinburgh yeah precisely yeah or new
castle or something like that
it's just not going to work and we're
not and we certainly don't have the
buildings or the infrastructure
or even you know the technical
infrastructure as well to one
um support electric electrification two
our roads are so bad that you know you
would never want an autonomous vehicle
to even attempt to drive it
landing on a royal mile in edinburgh
yeah exactly well that's it that's about
it it just goes up and down in a
straight line and that's great
the rest of it just forget it oh no
another pothole
[Laughter]
you know and then and then flying
vehicles or or attack or flying drone
taxis kind of sort of thing again you've
got that kind of
we don't have even the you know are we
going to have like mini
um air traffic control systems all over
the place
because every city is built different um
all the infrastructure you know the fact
that we don't have double decker trains
in the uk is because
we built you know like in amsterdam and
or in the netherlands it's because
our rail structure we have low bridges
because they never even considered it
so all we could do is just make trains
extra long
rather than doubling them up and having
doubling the capacity a different way
and it's the same with like
taxi infrastructure or flying
infrastructure or electrifications as
well
some cities have been built a specific
way that they just even didn't even
think about that
at all in the future and so it's going
to be very difficult to overlay
some advanced technological innovation
onto a really crumbling
old sort of victorian infrastructure
yeah
that's the problem of having a country
as old as ours in the uk right it's all
well and good
looking at dubai and seeing that oh well
you don't really have the the history
that we do or america and you say we've
existed for 250 years the oldest
building that you've got
doesn't really matter we've got all of
this beautiful history
but we also have roads that were
designed by a three-year-old that had
too many e numbers you know they've had
too much glucose and got let loose with
a sharpie pen
and it's squiggles and all over the
place
i mean to to sing the song for the
techno optimists in this
it seems to me like it's just it's a
coding problem
you just need to come up with a
sufficiently scalable advanced algorithm
that would be able to work out
and negotiate with the other vehicles
that are around
and can be sufficiently
understanding of the different types of
landscapes
in theory yes when it comes to the
issues of autonomous vehicles in general
and flying autonomous vehicles in
particular
what's really holding us back is not
actually the technology so much as it is
the people because we tend to forget
about this so just because it can be
done doesn't mean it will be allowed to
be done
the thing with autonomous vehicles is a
regulatory and
legal absolute nightmare and we have
become a very
timid species we no longer like risk
so the great analogy is if we invented
the motor car for the first time
this year in the year of fear and
loathing across the planet
would we have allowed anyone to get in a
vehicle that goes at 120 kilometers
an hour you know i don't think so you
see we've just got to a point where we
are very very afraid of each other we
sue each other for all sorts of things
and
we have allowed probably too much red
tape and too much safety isn't
crept into our society so i don't know
if there's a will
to get you know general mass transport
autonomous vehicles off the ground
that's the first thing
the second thing is of course that
flying cars in particular do require
quite a lot of space so once again if
you're in a very big city it's not
accessible for everyone to use these
things
you know there's only so much rooftop
space that you can land on so you can
imagine it sort of queues up elevators
instead of sort of
queues on the pavement for for taxis
there's simply less space
for these things to actually pick people
up so what you get to is a point where
essentially the same sort of people who
are able to use helicopters right now
get to use
these things instead but the other
regulatory issue that's going to
slow this down even if we are able to
overcome all the technological
challenges
is the eco movement and the fact that
even if these things are running on
renewable energy
they still have a higher carbon
footprint than your bicycle
and i live in south africa but i have
noticed with big eyes and a slight
amount of laughter
how europe is pushing back on any sorts
of progress
and is regressing to basically the
fastest speed that they
that one is encouraged to go at is the
speed of basically a two-speed bicycle
so we have to understand this is the
society that these things are being
launched into
which is why there's a very different
future ahead for your sort of
aging perhaps sort of paler colder
nations up north than they are for
perhaps some of the more vibrant
younger economies that have not yet lost
their nerves so to speak which is quite
interesting thing for me to say but
living in south africa we're kind of at
the
melting point of all these different
world views from east west north and
south
and there's a very different tint on the
future coming out of those societies
that's super interesting the fact that
culturally we
have muted our desire for rapid growth
there's a lot of i had alex epstein on
the show recently who is a pro
fossil fuels philosopher and researcher
and he was talking about
human racism as he calls it which is the
hatred of our own race and this is
you talk about destroying the planet and
using fossil fuels incorrectly and so on
and so forth you guys would love him you
should really check out his stuff
um i wonder whether you know the valley
of despair
that people have as part of a learning
curve i wonder if there's an equivalent
with the valley of comfort that we've
managed to get to now
so previously all of our problems were
problems of scarcity not problems of
abundance
we've now flipped that on its head it's
problems of abundance not scarcity
there could be more comfort more
abundance down the road
but i wonder whether we think well it's
all right now
this feels okay to me i don't need more
convenient travel i don't need more
whatever it might be x y and z
so we'll just stick here that we've
reached a point previou you know
i don't think i think it would have been
difficult to have justified a thousand
years ago
not continuing to develop all of the
things that we've had to but now we get
to a stage where you think okay so
i feel all right as a normal person i
don't really have too many problems so
why bother yeah comfort definitely slows
us down
from progress but i think that's also
quite a sort of first world sort of
perspective like i think there's a lot
of people who require quite a lot of
growth in my corner of the world and i
still want the more privileged corner of
the african continent
so i think that what i've definitely
noticed particularly with people that
work professionally in the sort of
future space and the policy space is
that we're getting messages
of not just we have enough coming from
europe and from
the greater west if you want to sort of
use that sort of summary
that actually pushes towards things like
d growth actually saying we should have
less but at the same time us sitting in
africa are saying oh we can't actually
do with less
we actually need quite a lot more so
there is quite a big
a big conflicts emerging there and i
thought it was quite interesting i
actually got yelled at on twitter today
for for commenting on how these messages
coming out of again europe saying that
the children are bad for the planet so
you shouldn't have any i mean like
that's a really privileged point of view
to actually start telling people that
people are bad we should save the planet
for these people that aren't going to be
born right we'll be saving it for
i find quite quite a lot of irony and
any sort of deep growth messaging
it just wells me completely the wrong
way we need to be finding ways to
sort of leave this place better than we
found it but also to progress
to something new because stagnation is
just death i mean
when we stop changing that's literally
the definition of deafness
in some terms so we have to be
optimistic about these things otherwise
we do sort of
call into a little ball and start
preaching de-growth and
you know the anti-natalist movements
which is about as about as pessimistic
as you can get
in terms of humanity but we're there
already and these movements are growing
right now
deaths of despair are increasing and
deaths from
suicide are now more common than deaths
from homicide at a global level
these things shall give us pause for
thought
about how pessimistic we've become as a
species even if we pretend otherwise
we're not acting
like we're optimistic and i find that
quite shocking because all the trends
are generally
pointing up we should be quite excited
it's quite a good time to be around in
fact
you look at the general lottery of life
you didn't know where you were going to
be born or to which parents and you were
told you could pick a date
this would be a pretty good bet i mean i
don't know if i want to
pick a date further back in history the
chances of having a decent life today
anywhere in the world are greater than
they were at any point
previously in history but we've
completely misplaced our
optimism i'm not quite sure why that is
maybe it's because we're too comfortable
maybe it's because we
are just a little bit we just naturally
dissatisfied envious species
i don't know if you've got some thoughts
there
um i'll go back to my my
my thoughts are on apathy um we have
become an apathetic species but i think
and
and maybe falling into that comfort zone
but i think
it's it's also a question of distraction
as well so we
a lot of the technology that we have
today around us today
is built to distract so we
you know generally um we
i agree with bronwyn that we are
actually living in a period of time
where things are abundant and we are
actually in a better state than we
ever have been in in the past but
people are apathetic to actually want to
find out that information and those
facts are themselves
and instead of fed that information to
the the negative side of that
information which is
oh woe is me everything is doom and
gloom this is the worst we've ever been
this is the worst state that humanity's
ever been in and they're fed that point
of view
and because there are they are in a
comfort zone and they are also
apathetic um they don't want to find out
any other information around that is
that the right point of view
do i just accept well i can't be
bothered you know oh someone's posted
something on facebook
oh there's a new tick tock here we go
this this will this will distract me
from the truth and what's actually
happening in the world today
and i think this is quite an an
interesting but also dangerous
place that we're in right now which is
there's a lot of people sleep walking
into the future
um at the moment and uh and completely
unaware of
all the good things that are happening
in the world today uh but completely
besotted with all the bad things
because these are the things that the
algorithms love to
serve up because it keeps us in that
kind of benign state
yeah from the valley of despair to the
comfort zone of apathy
we've managed to switch those around
what about work what's the future of
work looking like are we all going on
universal basic income are robots taking
our jobs what's happening
neither those were the two
those are the only two doors that i had
to go behind
[Laughter]
what's happening um i thought i i think
well
i'll let bronwyn speak on on some of
this as well but my
my thoughts are you know the robots
aren't going to take our job i think
what they're going to do is augment
certain functions that we perform
and hopefully allow us to do other
things
and allow us to explore other sides of
humanity this is what i would like to
see
um certainly you know i spoke about it
in a ted talk i did a couple of years
back as well on that kind of front
you know will will we ever follow a
robot leader or will we actually do
learn to be humans again um and i would
like to see this a golden age
or a renaissance where people just
rediscover the arts and humanities
and and go and paint something just
because not because there's no money in
it but because i actually want to
explore that side for myself and be
creative
i would like to see you know the
autonomy and the augmentation
allow us to switch to something like a
three or
four day week rather than speeding up
the productivity but filling in that
five days again
so we don't escape it i would like to
see us escape that a little bit
um on the the other door which i've
completely forgotten which one
oh universal basic income i always find
it really interesting
that the biggest supporters and the
biggest and the loudest voices of
universal basic income are the ones are
are are um are setting us up for these
kind of sort of traps of automation
and and um and and putting us in that
particular state to want
universal basic income so the bill gates
and the uh
and the elon musks and all that kind of
sort of thing if you look at their
history their history has all been about
software and automation and and you know
jeff bezos and things like that and and
making us work harder and faster to the
point where
uh but giving us nothing in return to
the point that we actually need
more to survive and they're the biggest
supporters of it and you get you have to
question whether it's a completely
flawed
system in the first place as a result of
that
yeah so in terms of sort of universal
basic income i think it's it follows on
quite nicely from our conversation and
de-growth it's always
amusing to me that rich young men in
silicon valley are the ones that want to
preach to us about why we should
accept to please so can i have some more
universal basic income future
at the same time it's also quite ironic
that it's rich
old men in political power in europe
that are trying to sell us some ideas of
d
growth which incidentally leads to the
same point because a lot of the
de-growth idea is about making do with
less about job sharing about like you
were talking about their
four-day work weeks which is i still i
think the wrong way to look at this
because they're still talking about sort
of master slave
owner employee type relationships where
we actually heading is into a post-job
world but not a post-work world there's
quite a big distinction there
jobs are an artifact of the industrial
revolution for that people were either
literally surfs or they were
hand-to-mouth sort of subsistence
farmers
you worked for yourself by yourself or
you were kind of a slave and you really
have a choice we don't really want to go
back to that
but that's kind of what i'm seeing is
going to happen because i don't see much
difference
from being a soap that has to till the
physical land in order to
get your allowance from the owner of the
means of production
compared to being a digital surf that
has to
you know either fall into the jobs works
program of your sort of mmt
toting heterodox economists in the west
or to ask very nicely for your tick
overlords to hand you an allowance or to
increase your alliance allowance the end
of every month
essentially as long as your ability to
survive is dependent on someone else he
sort of feeds you owns you so i don't
see any sort of universal basic enzyme
type
type proposal as being anything other
than a band-aid over a very
failed society what we are actually
working towards and i'm a bit more
optimistic about this than perhaps there
would be
so we are working towards a post-job
world
jobs are less and less attractive
particularly to young people even in my
country which has some of the highest
employment
and inequality rates in the world young
people don't want
[ __ ] jobs they want good jobs or
they prefer not to have a job at all
and this makes a lot of sense but of
course you can't have a society where
more people are dependent
on the state or handout and are
independent of it
so the only way to sort of resolve that
tension is for more people to become
independent or to become gainfully
unemployed as
as is actually someone like myself and i
think theo you've been gainfully
unemployed from
for a large part of your career which
comes with a lot less security than a
universal basic income or a salary would
give you but it also actually comes with
a lot more
freedom and it comes with the ability
for you to manage your own time and to
sort of
not work to live you know but to enjoy
the work that you're doing and work then
becomes a value equation
whereby we have to find ways the
challenge to individuals
to add value to society and if we don't
we are going to end up in a neo-serfdom
type
relationship where we are dependent on
someone else for a handout that can be
changed removed
or have added t's and c's attitude which
is what should scare us the most
because universal basic incomes are
going to be attached to things like your
health care
and to a whole lot of rules that come
with it i mean we've got smart toilets
now so if you're going to have your
universal basic income in universal
basic
healthcare you have to follow the rules
you're going to lose your privileges
right
so your toilet's going to know when
you've been eating badly or you haven't
been going to the gym and it's going to
tell on you
and that's a very sort of crass example
but that's the world we're kind of
working towards we have to understand
as long as we're getting stuff for free
we are the product even if we're getting
it for free from our states
whatever that case might be so the
alternative is to find a way to actually
add value to
your society and ironically many many
people in salary jobs are not adding
value to society that's quite harsh
words but
i'm sure many of us have met the
permafrost layers the management layers
and organizations
it was sort of collecting they check
passing go collect check
end of every month without adding value
to the organization and those people are
going to find themselves out of a job
they're going to find themselves out of
a job and out of work because unless you
found a way to add value to society
you are going to be someone else's
essentially
property but not everyone
is built to be a creator of some kind
adding we need to have the reason you
have stratified levels within
organizations is that there are people
with varying degrees of
conscientiousness
and intelligence and abilities and so on
and so forth
so what are you going to do for the
people at the bottom of that
all right the bottom half too worried
about the people at the bottom most of
the people at the bottom of our
societies and our economic ladders are
actually essential workers they were the
people that were still working last year
when we were all in lockdown
they weren't earning much money but they
were essential to society which means
they are actually adding value the sort
of people that aren't adding value
tend to be your over-privileged overpaid
white-collar workers in good jobs after
all the definition of a good job is
being paid more than you are worth
so let that settle into everyone's
listening and it feels like you you
ended up last year richer than you
started out even though you didn't work
too hard and you knew it
that wasn't me my fellow payment was
[ __ ] um but
if you think about presumably the people
at the bottom of that ladder are also
the ones whose jobs are going to be
close to the easiest to automate
so okay tell me about it because
any job that involves your hands that
involves your hands or your eyes or a
physical part of your body is much
harder to automate these are jobs in
roles like caring
and caring is of course going to be one
of the biggest industries coming forward
as our populations age and we're running
out of young people as we're talking
about sort of population degree
across vast swathes of our globe those
jobs are going to increase
things like being a pastor or personal
trainer are going to do just fine so in
other words if you're touching people
either spiritually or emotionally or
physically you're going to be okay
and they're much harder to automate it's
much more difficult and much more
expensive to create
a machine to pour a cup of coffee than
it is to create a piece of code that can
copy your insurance adjuster your
financial advisor's advice
so even within those roles that's why
financial advisors are having to shift
from selling products to actually giving
you
coaching and mentorship around your
financial
status so you've got to find where
you're actually adding value and where
you're just being a cost to the people
who are paying your bills
and there are portions and places to add
value in every different
industry or job function but you have to
find them because too many of us in too
many of our industries are bolt-on
essentially being sort of toll keepers
and collecting rents
is there enough room for everybody to
step into this
yeah i mean if you if you want to know
there's enough room for everybody to
either be a creator or to add value just
go look at
look at the people who are making a
living selling
their mediocre nfcs right now there's a
buyer for everything
[Laughter]
as long as you can persuade someone else
it's valuable to them
that's going to be good but don't think
you're going to get a salary from it
that is going to shift i do think
salaries are going to be something that
you don't want salary jobs are going to
be the sort of jobs you don't want to
have and only the desperate will be
taking
going forward what about people
space travel space travels like the
frontier of futurism right what's
what's what's the future of space travel
got in store for us
it's gonna happen finally
whether we whether we set up a
settlement on mars or the moon in the
next 50 years is something completely
different
um it's interesting i saw the um
is what's it called is it artemis or
gateway it's called gateway
um gateway which is like the uh the
lunar
basically the lunar version of the iss
and it's gonna serve as some sort of hub
for to to shuttle you know rich folk to
the moon and back and
or to the mars and back and act as a
staging post and it'll be permanently
manned and things like that
and it always makes me laugh because you
see these programs like the expanse in
star trek and star wars and
they paint you know the expanse is
probably the closest
um vision of the future and it's
certainly a very dystopian one anyway
um but at the same time
it still doesn't paint a very realistic
picture
in in the sense that space is very hard
so failure is always going to be on a
big scale
so at some point you know when ellen
musk boards his space rocket there's
going to be a tiny part of him that's
going to be [ __ ] his pants
because that payload might go up in his
face so for one
it there's a big risk there too living
in space is actually really really hard
on the human body if you've ever seen an
astronaut coming back down from iss
after a 200 days stay they are
literally crippled they have muscle
atrophied
um they can barely stand on their own
now if you can imagine us
you know saying i'm going to live on
mars which has you know a different set
of atmospheres a different set of
gravity
and the same on the moon as well and
then thinking about the journey to get
there
having a little two-week holiday and
then the journey to get back to earth
for example
uh you know that's going to wreck the
human body
um and i just don't think that the
species at this point in time and
technologically
we're advanced enough to be settling
so it's essentially a one-way trip
the other thing as well is if you notice
the the complaints from the astronomy
point of view um of starlink as well so
at the moment we are literally lit
littering the skies with satellites with
little bits of space junk as well
and it's becoming harder and harder for
us to actually track
i believe and then i think in the future
we'll see this sort of scenario where
wally got it right where the earth is
literally cocooned by all these dead
satellites or just this this horrible
you know cocoon of metal and it's going
to become ever more increasing risk
to actually travel to the stars until we
sort that out as well
so there are inherent you know there are
known risks which are
you know space is hard even the the
financial side is incredible
failure is spectacular um and it's
really hard on the human body and then
you've got all the
all the uh actual physical risks in
terms of
you know risk to the body you've got the
risks of
space and space junk up there you've got
radiation as well
um from you know from the from the sun
and from the
space in general um it's it's not going
to be an easy thing
um and i i wish people would read up a
little bit more rather than looking at
the
fanciful renders and uh the the movies
out there that paint a very
utopian version of what life is gonna be
like
um because it's gonna be indentured
servitude
and one-way trips for the people who who
actually want to pay to get there
presumably though if the people that are
going
are the ones that have the money if the
companies that are
giving the service to them are refining
their
payloads and their rockets and the
technology that they use and
everything else if you want to repurpose
people that have too much money's money
to companies that want to take their
money to research it to make
essentially democratize or at least
bring the cost down for future space
travel
surely that's a good thing oh i mean
this
this is no different to chris columbus
and all these other people
who've built a boat financed the boat
and then thought you know sod it let's
take a chance
stick you know fill this boat up with
some intrepid people and let's go and
explore the brave new world
you know it's exactly the same thing but
just on a completely different scale
um so those p you know to the to the
victor go the spoils in a sense
you know the people who set foot on mars
who or
the moon who build the first colony
survive propagate
you know the world you know they'll be
known as the pioneers the true pioneers
you know at the moment we're at this
kind of sort of weird stage where
everyone everyone believes that this
crazy
guy who claims he has autism is that is
the future of mankind
um and i think we just need a bit more
um realism injected into that vision
first
but but certainly you know the the it's
um
it's a it's a grand prize um you know
no bones about it this one's a grand
prize but it's certainly up
it's certainly going to take real
pioneers to get there you're not a fan
of your own
stop trying um he um
you know i he's an interesting character
i'm not a great fan of him i i think
there are flashes of
brilliance in what he does sometimes you
know
in you know what he's done with tesla
off off the back
of workers i might add it's not just him
um you know tents full of people
sweating their arses off to get
cars out the door of the shoddy panels
um
and things like that but you know you
know um
and then what he's done with spacex i
think is fantastic in terms of lowering
the cost and democratizing that and
taking that away from
you know agency control where it's just
we have to just trust nasa to do it all
kind of sort of thing
he's now commercialized space um
but i think the um
i i think he kind of brings himself down
with all the weird stuff that he gets on
with
an old crypto thing and the odd tweets
and getting into
you know instead of picking up the phone
he should maybe just like pick up the
next sketchbook and do something
you know and do something wonderful
again you know like his namesake you
know on on
on his uh you know on his company logo
tesla you know dream up some big
wonderful ideas again
you know the boring company another
classic example i'm going to
tunnel under the earth and and take away
all the congestion and it's going to be
automated highways under the ground
and in the end it was just a tunnel that
you drive through with flashing lights
that would probably give you a headache
you don't trigger off an epileptic fit
and cause a crash
so you know sometimes he does something
fantastic and
and then you know three out of four
times you know he just
he just could he's a complete dick yeah
it's interesting thinking about people
like that i often think about the price
that we need to pay to be the people
that we admire
and you know if the byproduct of having
democratized space travel and
commercialized it so that
people can go up and the future
generations you know at these inflection
points earlier in the development of
technology
you are setting the tone so much more
importantly than you would be down the
line because you're
essentially opening up different
branches of potential futures right when
you do this thing
and if the price that we need to pay is
to have
like the donald trump of tech
[Laughter]
tweeting away which is totally and i i i
think
elon's he's an interesting guy i i like
the the sort of tony stark
real world crazy tony stark thing that
we've got going on
it would be more optimal if he he just
had his company look after his twitter
account but again that's perhaps the
price that we need to pay
the price that you need to pay to have
the guy that thinks those things is also
the fact that he's going to try stuff
like putting a tunnel underneath
la that perhaps doesn't necessarily work
what about health what's happening
what's the future of our health going to
look like
which future of health i mean like
there's there there are two
very divergent views in terms of health
which is i think coming back to the elon
conversation there's people who want to
progress and there's people that want to
regross and elon's an interesting guy
because
he's one of the few people that is
actually building doing taking risks
making new things which also quite
associates it with
a whole lot of the the really rich
people who don't have a god or a meaning
in their lives
that are wanting to live forever so
you've got people that are pushing for
immortality
which would be not even it's not real
immortality let's put it that way but
just trying to
find ways in order to get their
consciousness or their essence
to be passed down to the rest of
humanity because they believe they are
the super
sort of ubermensch of the world of our
generation
but on the other hand you've got people
that are desperately wanting to shorten
their lifespans
you see things like euthanasia on the up
everywhere
i haven't i haven't been exposed to
people wanting to shorten their lives
the euthanasia thing is huge isn't that
people that are already dying
though right they're not actually die
they're not healthy people that are
wanting to die some of them are just old
people
rocky right we tied now we're done
so and that's sick of this place if elon
musk tweets one more time
i swear to god quite natural i think
lots of people get tired after a while
especially if you are
thinking that the future is not going to
be any more exciting or you could get
sick or that you're going to start
declining but there are definitely
people out here that don't
value any life at all much less their
own i think that's the growing subtext
of the the apathy and of the sort of
anti-growth and
anti-progress narrative it does spill
over into that quite dramatically
and if you look at the sort of
categories of where where people are
pushing for things like euthanasia to be
or like compassion it's killing whatever
if there's different sort of legal
categories
to be legalized you can see those
categories get broader and broader not
just for people that are
you know have terminal illnesses i mean
technically we all do right to be all
mortal unless you try try push for the
digital immortality route on the other
side
which seems to be the most likely way to
do it of course digital immortality
comes with a 100
fatality rate up front but then your
consciousness can be cloned and off you
can go that seems like the most likely
way we're able to do this
infinite life extension doesn't look
like it's going to be
achievable within our life spans that's
not to say that it won't
but much like the issue with
civilization ending events like you were
talking about earlier
like one guy blowing up the species with
a misplaced you know printing of some
sort of smallpox virus in his home
printer
you know it the odds are eventually
compound against your favor even if
you're able to renew your physical body
in terms of
preventing illness sooner or later
accident or injury catch up with you
and and that's the sort of threat that
comes with trying to pursue immortality
as as
health but that is definitely the
direction we're going to
where it's from from a sort of
individual perspective
doing things that puts you in the
position of injury or illness gets more
and more frowned upon
at the same time healthcare costs
increase because of course everybody
wants access to every sort of life
extending treatment that exists for us
which puts huge pressure onto social
security safety nets on the other hand
you've got sort of
really really wealthy people who are
able to purchase all of these things
and to postpone their lives as long as
possible
pouring huge and huge huge amounts of r
d into these fields too
actually doing quite interesting things
with dogs if you are a pet lover
they're making quite good progress on
extending the life of you how old can
you get your dog to be
at the moment well they're busy messing
around with it right now so this is like
a there's quite a prominent
company i'm not gonna mention names it's
attracting quite a lot of funding at the
moment and they say they should be able
to sort of extend your pet's
lifespan for sort of 20 even up to
doubling it eventually
they're hoping to use the same
technology on humans so we can look
forward to a longer much more expensive
life with many many many more rules
that say what we are are not allowed to
do if we do want access to those
those life-extending treatments so it
becomes a case of quality or quantity of
life how long would you like
to live if you were never allowed
another glass of wine another cigarette
or you weren't ever allowed to drive in
a car or go up to space because those
are all things that could result in
expensive insurance payouts
for your your public or private sector
insurer
so that's the sort of the the sort of
overview of healthcare where we're
trying to look now at life extension
rather than just
curing disease but actually preventing
the prevention also comes with increased
bio surveillance and increased
biohacking if you're doing it yourself
but it means basically living your
living your life what you have of it
around maintaining your health which can
become a bit
obsessive for anyone that understands
things like eating disorders
and exercise disorders it's almost it
can take over your life so
i suppose that's a that's a sort of
broad picture in terms of
how we can we can we can kill ourselves
by trying to keep ourselves alive
or how far are we prepared to go in that
pursuit
it's interesting to think about the fact
that when your life is potentially
infinite or is negligibly finite in
terms of how long it goes away from you
you do do a cost benefit analysis
on every action that you take and
you're just going to end up potentially
with an entire society of people that
got agrophobia
and they're unprepared to leave the
house because at the moment
the likelihood of me being hit by a car
versus the remaining
50 years of my life i think well you
know it's all right 50 years
if you're thinking okay it's 50 000
years that you've potentially got or 500
years or
you know even 150 years well i'm
weighing this up against
the the scales are tilting now in a very
interesting
because it's everything every potential
life-ending injury accident illness
eventually becomes more probable given a
long enough timeline
so we have to become more and more
obsessive about trying to prevent these
things from happening to us and that can
be hugely mentally distressing
especially if you imagine you had been
able to keep yourself alive for a couple
of hundred years and then you sort of
literally get like killed by a crow
dropping out of the sky and a freak
accident right you'd be quite you'd be
quite annoyed at that
it also make you hugely hugely paranoid
so
you know the longer we extend our
lifespans the more afraid we get
of death on the one hand on the other
hand you've got other people just want
to opt out that want them
want to take the early exit which i do
think is quite interesting
in terms of you it's interesting it's
interesting because you've got
you know if you're if you if you have
that if you have the means the financial
means to say i want to add another 100
years to my life
you know um you're going to get that
treatment potentially up front so it's a
wad of cash and then you're going to
feel
well this investment has cost me a lot
of money so i'm going to have to protect
the investment yeah and i'm going to
stay inside or you get this situation
where it's like immortality as a service
where you're paying a subscription fee
to get your monthly job and if you can't
if you can't afford the job any longer
then essentially you know oh no i'm
going to lose the benefit of this
healthy
extended lifestyle and i'm going to die
next week so
it's and then what have you got to live
for for a start i mean let's put it this
way it's not
unless you are rich and have means are
you going to really
fall back on the state pension if there
is one at that point in time
is the state going to be happy that
you're going to live another 50 years
and not actually contribute to society
because you're you're claiming a pension
off them or are they going to force you
to work in your retirement age now is
that 130
and not 65 or 75 you know and if that's
the kind of life that you're going to
look forward to then again
i'm booking a flight to dignitas
what would be good for you yeah exactly
you've got to
you've got to go you've missed your
payment this month off you go
see you later on go through this tunnel
um what
are your thoughts on whether or not
we're going to have a
super intelligent artificial general
intelligence within the next
100 years i'll buy 2100
i would put them on the low odds on that
one and i know i'm probably in the
minority of people that do think in the
future space
i'm not convinced that consciousness is
an emerging phenomenon that we can
recreate
i know once again that doesn't put me
necessarily with the majority of
philosophers out there but then again i
don't necessarily respect
the majority of contemporary
philosophers
around these days but better or worse
and you get in trouble for saying such
things
i think it's quite a huge assumption to
believe that we are able to recreate
that jump when we're not able to
understand it and we haven't seem to
come any closer to help solving
not even all the soft problems of
consciousness let alone the hard ones
do you need consciousness to have
general intelligence
yeah pretty much eventually you would
because the thing with with
general intelligence is would have to
act like us that would have to have a
will it wouldn't just be a program
so you could have a very very
complicated intelligence that's smarter
than us
in many many domain functions but in
order for it to become a general
intelligence it requires a will
which means that it would need to either
have a will to to do good to do bad or
to change the direction that it had been
programmed in
in order for it to become general it has
to act independently from how it was
programmed
so that goes way beyond complexity or to
chaos theory
into having something else that is what
real general intelligence is
to have domain specific general
intelligence i think we're already there
if you pick any particular human
function we can program something to do
it better
faster smarter you know that's that's
that's the way it works
but at the same time until that that
intelligence is able to
coalesce and to actually direct itself
to choose to do things which we don't
even really understand how
we do we sort of have vague ideas but
not proper ideas
then we're not going to make that leap
so whether we make that leap or not is
about as
as sort of plausible as to getting into
the really big questions as to whether
there's
there's a god or gods or not right i
mean it's a very very big assumption
these are the basic
assumptions and questions of philosophy
that the ancient greeks have been
debating that we haven't really got much
further than running around in circles
over the last few thousand years i don't
know if you agree theo so i'd say
there's a possibility but i put in the
pretty low odds yeah same um i'm in the
same mind
uh camps and camp regarding intelligence
and the fact that um
you know agi requires uh requires world
choice and spontaneity and creativity as
well so
like real creativity not programmed one
beyond programming right
yeah exactly um and we're just not there
yet
um i think we will never we won't see
um just one all-encompassing skynet
either i mean there are so many
uh initiatives out there to race to
create the first one anyway
what we're going to actually see is
probably a few if there are ever
an emergent agi or certainly domain
specific agis or ones that
coalesce like um bronwyn says um that
creates
you know that creates one but has
specific elements of other domains
um there's got to be several um i mean
you look at facebook with
that had m before um google's ai
assistant you've got open ai doing stuff
with gpt3 and things like that um alexa
siri they're all shades of something
that's very weak at the moment it's the
same with tesla's car
that's a domain specific intelligence
that will get you from a to b
as safely as possible but it's not going
to do your maths homework or complete a
thesis or anything else like that
or draw a picture um but we will see
i think shades of agi um
and there will be more than one there's
not going to be a skynet
that rules everything there will be more
than one and
if there ever were a real agi to emerge
by 2100 and if there ever were
one or more agi that's when i think
things might get interesting
that's when nick got needs to be raised
from wherever he is
buried in oxford in 2100 and like look
nick we really
we really need you really need you back
mate so neither of you two
believe that consciousness comes along
for the ride with information processing
then
that it's not just a case of scaling up
the amount of information processing
there is something else in there
some sort of special something that
layers on top
yeah i mean it's something we don't
understand if we don't understand it we
can't program it
so you know to think that that it
magically appears that it emerges
without being programmed into something
that has been programmed and built from
us from scratch
that requires a leap of faith or belief
or basically sort of belief in something
that you cannot prove
so which is basically the same thing as
trying to say that you believe in a god
right that's believing something that
cannot be proved
because we don't know what it is we can
only program what we know how to program
we can get things to do things faster
than us
smarter than us we can combine functions
but
in order to try and imagine the
technology will do something that it
hasn't actually been built to do
i think puts quite a probably too much
faith in our own ability
right that is a big logical step right
to take it
from what we're doing at the moment
which is super human
to super intelligent yeah so that's not
to say that machines won't be smarter
than us to be able to make better
decisions than us
but but to actually think of having a
general intelligence
is is quite a specific claim that
i'm not convinced that we're very i
don't think we know enough to program
that
i don't think that oh it's like alchemy
right so you can think you can combine
all the elements but it doesn't
spontaneously turn into gold you're kind
of missing that
that last step so we've got everything
together it was sort of almost like the
cargo cult right you know sort of build
it and it will come
[Laughter]
what do you think of course i know
computer scientists are going to
disparage us hugely from this
you're just destroying their entire
industry yeah exactly
um what are your thoughts on whether or
not
the human race reaches its full
civilizational potential
i'm big into existential risk and if
super intelligent agi a misaligned one
stuart russell's human-compatible he
doesn't need to worry and
toby or he doesn't need to worry at
least for a little bit of his work and
nick bostrom wrote super intelligence
basically just as a
fiction book for us all to have a look
at if that's potentially out the window
and that's that's off the table at least
is with regards to a risk
what are your confidences that we end up
let's say colonizing the galaxy before
we wipe our race out you think it's
going to happen
well i suppose it depends on how deep
you mean by colonization i think we're
going to keep on pushing until we do get
to them
get to mars and get to the moon i'm not
sure how happy we'll be there because i
mean
as much as we are you know pessimistic
about the earth's own prospects i think
it's still nice to live in siberia that
would
be to live on mars from the pictures
i've seen anyway so
you know how happy we will be there and
if it takes into being a sort of a
thriving community is of course a
different question
and a lot of the reasons why people are
pushing for sort of intergalactic
settlement is because of worries over
sort of earth's sustainability
but if our problems change for having
too many people to having too
few people before we actually get those
sort of colonies started
that becomes a very very different
question i think we sort of have to bear
that in mind
and that it looks like our population
curve is going to start bending over
faster than we would have initially
thought and then of course
you're not sort of meeting your
population replacement rates that
becomes quite a different
existential challenge for humanity when
you look at the far enough timelines to
be talking about intergalactic
settlements you're talking after many
many
generations and if over that time your
population is shrunk
those whole sort of challenges change i
think bigger risks
to our sort of flourishing and more
realistic risks in fact that i think
that are almost
inevitable as opposed to general
intelligence which is which is
hypothetical it is something we can
consider it's a possibility it won't
rule it out but it's not sort of
inevitable the way i see it right now
i think that is almost inevitable that
we are going to
embark in fact we already have on
intelligent design which is also written
about in the book there in crave craig's
chapter with the sort of
homo i think he called it he made it up
himself that word so i can
pronounce it he just he looked and
looked in a latin
sort of dictionary and picked it out but
the whole thing of intelligent design is
happening and that is going to
accelerate our fulfillment as a species
or accelerate our demise depending on
how we deal with that sort of post-human
transition
and that is i think something that i'm
much more interested in than agi is a
separate entity rather the combining of
humanity with technology from a
biological perspective and from a
hardware perspective
all of those technologies are converging
at the same time and
i'm probably more certain that we'll
either sort of you know
either augment our own intelligence the
point we become sort of human general
intelligence before we actually create
an artificial
general intelligence and that's just as
dangerous so i know once again a lot of
people would
disagree with that race as to whether
humans become too smart for our own good
or
too smart for what is currently the
human species we actually sort of
transcend that that will sort of level
up as a species
i think we'll probably do that before
sort of artificial intelligence
spontaneously generates its own
consciousness and will
you think the way things are headed
yeah yeah or another war i mean lose it
right
if you're talking about the flourishing
of humanity across the solar system and
things like that i mean like you say
we'll probably get to a stage where we
will
colonize or certainly set fruit and set
something up on mars and the moon
as the most i guess easiest habitable
options getting further is takes
uh is going to take us a hell of a long
time i think
given the resources and the constraints
and again all the risks
associated with space travel and we're
just not there yet with
other means of space travel or certainly
safer means and faster means as well
so you know we have a long way to go
certainly maybe
500 a thousand years to try and imagine
are we actually going to make it that
far or will we cause something
again whether it's a war on earth or
whether it's even our first
interplanetary war where
the mark the martian colonies think we
don't want to be part of your
disgusting mess anymore and we and the
earth people say or the terrans
say no you must come under our rule once
more you've been watching too much of
the expanse again haven't you thea
they haven't even got there yet i've
never read the martian constitution
they've declared independence from youth
and it's very equitable
it's it's it's super work okay is that
the thing
they've got a constitution for mars yeah
the martian constitution is
published you can go look that up yeah
who wrote this it's like it puts the
south african constitution to shame it's
very
happily written who created it
you know they were going to send that
whole mars colony so i know about it
from
adriana murray who was one of the chosen
astronauts yeah
so they were all it was all part of that
mars one thing that it came out of
i don't think mars one exists anymore
but
no it doesn't no the crowd funding
failed spectacularly didn't
uh i've been learning a little bit about
astropolitics about the politics of
space who owns areas of space who owns
the moon who owns mars
that's just no one owns anything
possession in that case i think it's
first come first service
indigenous populations you know all
these microbes that say that they were
here first
um bring your own microbes giving
given the how would you say the
overbearing positive nature of most of
futurism as far as i get to see right
the articles that are written and stuff
like that how
are how are the things that you guys
talk about
how is your narrative received generally
among the futurist community because i
imagine that it must be
this hyper realism perhaps where you're
saying what about this and
wait what about that i imagine it must
feel like someone's coming in and
pissing on their party a little bit
well i think you've got to understand
there's different groups of futurists
academic futurism is hugely pessimistic
there are too pessimistic that's what
i'm saying right at the beginning those
views are very binary
academic futurism is obsessed with
climate change and degrowth
they're all pushing for sort of like
fully automated
very low and middle class communism as a
solution to sort of you know
climate change and sustainability which
is a a very sort of
european view on the future i probably
shouldn't say that but that's kind of
the perspective i get that
it matches very neatly with the sort of
eu sort of development goals
it's very hard to separate academic
futurism from the eu's plans for the
future
and it's sustainability orientated and
smaller not larger
ride a bike don't take a rocket right so
that's that's
that's the one sided feature is it and i
i do have a degree in futurism so i kind
of understand what i'm talking about
there
the other side is of course the sort of
more sort of techno-futurism
realm which i know theo is sort of
skirting around which is the
tick evangelists and the hugely
optimistic ones but again they're
selling stuff so there's a huge amount
of cynicism there
so they might find us a bit annoying but
only in that we sort of messing up their
marketing plans not that we're really
challenging their ideas
so yeah i suppose there's supposed to be
somewhere in the middle and like anyone
that's kind of in the middle you don't
tend to be very popular with your peers
but we have found with this particular
book that because we're talking like
actual human beings we're not trying to
talk down to people about these ideas
let's be very well received by by people
that don't have a formal
or at least a paid background in
futurism that i
don't have a vested monetary interest in
pushing a particular
view it's an interesting one
it's an interesting one to think about
the potentials for our future
and how many biases and agendas
different people are pushing when
they're talking about it i mean if
there's one
future always it always comes with an
agenda
and it's and you have to see past that
because people the best thinkers in the
world
confuse us because the best people are
describing the world as it is from us
from a completely positive or
deterministic perspective
are also generally the best thinkers and
the best talkers which means they are
very persuasive when it comes to
slipping in
there are more normative ideas and
that's where people
get the whirlpool over their eyes
because we listen to someone we know
they're right about describing the world
as it is
and when they subtly start leading us by
the nose as to what should be talking
about instead of what is into what
should be
we end up being sort of drawn along into
the inevitability of these plans
and that nobody's making it clear where
they stop from describing and to
prescribing what should happen
everyone is slightly disingenuous about
that everyone's selling something a
policy an
election a product and you have to sort
of separate that from that or just a
keynote right i mean of course it's easy
to sell keynotes if you're talking about
yay
technology exponential curves i mean you
know the sphere i know this
we have to separate the the description
and the the reality
from from the sales pitch and people
have to question that otherwise you do
get sucked in
i love it theo priestly and bronwyn
williams ladies and gentlemen
the future starts now expert insights
into the future of business technology
and society will be linked in the show
notes below
where else should people go if they want
to check out your stuff
um well i'm on linkedin or twitter
mostly
um uh t priestly uh with all the uh
vowels removed because i'm so hip and
trendy like every startup these days
um or theo priestly on uh on linkedin um
not not too far behind every meme i
suppose
yeah i'm also likewise easiest to find
on twitter or linkedin
at brian williams on both come and fight
with me about consciousness and
artificial general
intelligence over theirs i'm sure i'm
sure intelligent
listeners of this show would have
something to say but that's the point we
invite you to disagree with us
please disagree with us don't take
anything we say is gospel
i love it guys thank you so much for
today thank you
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace
you